hey guys and welcome to the first
episode of statistically challenged new
series on Orthodox RS throughout this
series we will test some uncommon
money-making methods to see their
viability in today's game for the first
episode statistically challenged will
bring you one hour of picking up Ash
hope you
enjoy let's jump into it
[Music]
sing the song for a broken
hearted no silent prayer for the fa
[Music]
departed I going to be just a face in
the crowd you're going to hear my voice
I shut it out
loud It's my life and it's now never I
ain't going to never for
forever I just want to Live While I'm
Alive it's my life my heart is like an
open Highway friend said I did it my way
I just want to Live While I'm
Alive It's My
[Music]
Life only the one who stood ground
never tomor harder make no mistake you
luck a even luck you'll have to make
your own breaks it's my life and it's
not I going to live
forever I just want to live while Li
Al it's my life my heart is like an open
Highway
said I my way I don't want to live
another
life it's my
[Music]
[Applause]
so I just finished 1 hour of Ash picking
the total spoils are 1,100 194 ashes so
if we drop this into the price checker
we can see that we made 78k and that's
pretty good for an early level
moneymaking method only involves
Gathering and clicking so the gold per
hour will depend on how many fires are
being burned on your world in addition
to your agility level so Choose Wisely
overall you should average within 70k to
100K depending on those two factors so I
hope you enjoyed leave a like comment
and subscribe if you want to see more of
the content